hey guys how's it going so i'm really
really excited because we are about to
unbox the new nintendo 3ds xl right now
how's it going jen where's mine um
february 13th do you see what i
see nintendo 3ds hurry up
ready
oh my gosh it smells fresh and new
smells like a factory the first thing
you notice is it does not come with an
ac adapter
which thankfully i have one for my old
ds but i'll probably have to get one on
amazon
open it i am just kind of reveling in
its beautifulness
this is gonna be the shortest video
known to man because i just did the
unboxing already it's over it's here
it's beautiful um
are you are you not paying attention to
the video are you tweeting over there i
was actually on twitter okay i'm gonna
turn it on it's nice it's a gray it is a
gray so this is the black edition but
it's like a gray it is it's a little bit
it's not black black it's like a nice
charcoal gray i like that better i do
like it and it's shiny too
oh look on
oh my gosh so the first thing is you're
going to notice that they moved the
the volume button right here so i did
get a chance to test this out not too
long ago and i kept trying to use the
volume button here but the volume button
has moved up here and the cartridge slot
is now moved to the front no yeah
because it used to be back here oh they
also move the power button right here
so we're booting up oh i'm so excited
you have not tried this yet there's the
new face tracking 3d which is it's so
impressive i want you to try it because
i have experienced this before so you
you remember on the old dfs yes how i
actually i'm not even going to lie to
you i hardly ever played in 3d i never
did it because anytime you would even
move the screen around you would lose
the 3d so you had to use it at a very
specific angle but now with the face
tracking it's able to track your eyes
and your face and it will know
hey
this this chick is losing her mind she's
absolutely out of control give him hold
him he's lonely
okay great next holy moly
so yeah when you move it around it
doesn't you still see the 3d
hello
legend of zelda majora's mask
it comes this is neat right isn't it i
want you to play in 3d i want i want
just just to see your experience when
you play i'll just take this one then no
no no no no so this is the legend of
zelda majora's mask 3d this is the skull
kid this is the limited edition it comes
with a game it also comes with skull kid
figurine so you
so get that set up i'm sinking into my
face
oh he's gonna look
so good
next to all of my amiibo
oh my god i look at the home button it's
like real like
here i am
here i am what do you think of the
c-stick so this is a new c-stick what do
you think of this c-stick i like it so
the c-stick is pretty sensitive to touch
like it's not an actual button it's it
is a button but it's not a button it's a
c-stick it's the c-stick so if you guys
are playing smash brothers this is how
you're gonna smash oh i also wanted to
show you guys this so a friend of a
friend is a jewelry designer and she
asked me if i wanted to have my name
made custom on a ring and i said uh no i
do not shout out g-rock lay
it says nintendo
are you kidding me it's beautiful
okay ready open
one two three
alright guys thank you so much for
watching i will be doing a couple other
videos here with a new 3ds xl i'll
probably show you guys how to do a data
transfer but it's actually really late
right now and i'm going to go to bed so
this will have to wait until tomorrow
good
i know
i'm so excited alright guys i love you
i'll see you soon